a news survey says the supply of baby
formula powder is at its lowest level in
stores since the shortage began earlier
this year
the research firm iri found more than 21
percent of all formula products are out
of stock nationwide that number jumps to
more than 31 percent for powdered
formula the fda now plans to review its
own handling of this crisis but the
shortage is still affecting families now
and that's the problem meg oliver spoke
to two moms who say it's harder than
ever to feed their kids
i've been searching everywhere for julia
morgan and her eight-month-old daughter
tatum finding formula is a daily
struggle how much formula do you have
left right now about a week and a half
how desperate do you feel right now not
being able to provide for your infants
horrible it's it's the worst feeling you
feel helpless and um
very desperate tatum is lactose
intolerant and needs a hypoallergenic
formula or she gets very sick did you
think this would continue on for so long
no i did not i thought i was in the
clear because i had like two months
supply so i was like oh by the time i
run out they'll definitely have this
resolved i did not know this would still
be lingering on in february formula
maker abbott's largest plant shut down
for possible contamination before the
recall abbot was responsible for 40
percent of domestic baby formula and
that same month formula manufacturer say
they alerted retailers to an upcoming
shortage but in june president biden
admitted that he didn't know about the
looming problem until months later i
became aware of this problem
sometime in
after april in early april about how
intense it was
and so we did everything in our power
from that point on to counter the
shortage the biden administration
launched operation fly formula in may
which by the end of this week will have
delivered 61 million eight ounce
equivalent bottles of formula since may
health and human services secretary
javier becerra where does the baby
formula shortage stand right now as of
today we domestically see more product
more baby formula being produced
than we saw several months ago adding to
the supply problem that same abbott
plant had to close because of flooding
which backed up production even more it
reopened july 1st but there are still
delays to store shelves abbott remains
one of only four main companies that
provide about 90 percent of domestic
baby formula in the u.s we also want to
change the policy here
the industry
allowed themselves to be short
and we can't afford that especially with
specialty formula we're going to work to
make sure that they cannot allow
a disruption in a plant that closes down
to disrupt the availability of the
supply that parents need but that future
action would be too late for those like
eight-year-old izzy bradford who we
first met in may she's a third grader
who suffers from a rare disorder known
as pku and relies on a special formula
for about 70 percent of her nutrition
her mom sarah chamberlain says the
hunter formula now
is worse we have less formula than we
did two months ago it's still a scramble
yeah definitely in the last two months i
don't feel like anything has changed i
think we need to recognize this as a
hunger crisis that we have been facing
since february
for cbs mornings i'm meg oliver